[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ministres tués par leurs concitoyens
on est loin du scénario espéré par le
gouvernement britannique pour cette
session extraordinaire du parlement
boris johnson souhaitait un appui clair
à l'entente arraché à bruxelles
il y a deux jours venus dire adieu au
tokyo
en matinée le premier ministre parlait
d'un accord qui pourrait finalement
permettre de réaliser le président et de
panser les plaies
la société britannique il avait même
l'appui de sa prédécesseure de visas
mais était-ce contre le fautif a noté
octets qui espéraient que le pays puisse
finalement aller de l'avant après toutes
ces hésitations mais encore une fois les
élus en ont décidé autrement
ça vous savez savez une défaite sur un
amendement qui oblige pas question de
semaines a demandé un report de
l'échéance du prêt xix une décision qui
a réjoui des centaines de milliers de
britanniques réunies près du parlement
réclame un autre référendum sur la
question à dubaï
il a une âme
ne veulent pas céder dernier mot à boris
johnson mais attention le premier
ministre lui ne veut pas pour autant
changé 4 google cheick hadley wood et
nous restions ne se répète qu'il ne
négociera pas un quatrième report du
président
le gouvernement espère que tous les
projets de loi et le divorce pourront
être adoptés avant l'échéance du 31
octobre
c'est dans onze jours un calendrier
législatif serré qui pourrait de nouveau
être perturbé par les élus britanniques
ici yannick dumont baron radio-canada
paris